felix und toni kroos sind bei uns die
wir sehr herzlich begrüßen normal
[Applaus]
ob das paket den kulissen ein bisschen
gesehen so eure harmonie das ist wird
nicht gespielt die es ihr seid wirklich
ziemlich beste freunde
ich glaube das kann man so sehen wir
freuen uns natürlich extrem würden wir
uns sehen was leider nicht allzu häufig
der fall ist telefoniert die regelmäßig
ja und schreiben das hat das neue
telefonieren macht schickt den
sprachnachrichten oder so zeugen jaja
whatsapp nachrichten hier und da mal ein
foto und so weiter aber wir haben schon
kontakt aber wir freuen uns natürlich
wenn wir uns dann auch noch persönlich
sehen das nicht so oft und dann felix
wie heißt denn diese whatsapp gruppe zu
zweit haben wir keine gruppe werden
versagen seiner gegründet ja ist geile
typen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der manchmal muss man die dinge auch mal
beim namen nennen die sagen was sony hat
der gründer von der ich habe mich in der
vorbereitung gefragt hat man eigentlich
dann auch so eine whatsapp gruppe in der
cristiano ronaldo drin ist oder so
hatten wir natürlich eine eine
mannschafts gruppe insgesamt muss ich
das ja ja selbstverständlich also ist ja
nicht mehr drin jetzt alles raus was
schreibt man das so rhein-main neuer
lamborghini wie es bei dir und so naja
ich hab da mal ein audi ist auch schön
ja was was schreibt man da so täglich
also ja also es ist besser wenn man
nicht alles was sich ein fußballer
gruppenpreis gibt aber natürlich ist
auch mal so erst im spiel ist
besprechung ja keiner verschläft immer
und dann kriegt man dann vielleicht weil
du darüber
irgendwie dass er kommt oder irgendwas
gibt es auch wie gesagt sachen die die
sollte man auch nicht so sagen ja ich
war ja nachbarn in madrid so wichtig die
tür an tür quasi gewohnt jacke und
cristiano ronaldo kommt da mal zum
grillen vorbei und bringt so etwas
verrücktes veneto für wurst vorbei oder
ja dass das eher weniger also die fanden
eher die etwas lauteren bei ihm statt
allerdings war ich da auch relativ
selten dann die haben meist eine andere
uhrzeit lose grillen als wir von der
grünen haben ja ich kann mir ja mal dann
so jetzt mal also von unserer seite aus
alles in ruhe da drüben
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
es ist eine schöne vorstellung cristiano
ronaldo die polizei ins haus zu schicken
wegen belästigung also weiter ging's mit
lernen wir leistung ist großartig ich
habe noch die geschichte im kopf fällt
mir gerade ein mannschaftskollege von
ihm von manchester united noch gespielt
hat
der sagte irgendwann in einem interview
wendig cristiano ronaldo zum grillen
einlädt geht auf gar keinen fall hin und
zwar mit der begründung da kommst du hin
es gibt dann irgendwie nur gesundes
essen und dann geht es direkt wieder zum
training
und wenn man das kann man nicht machen
muss ja zwischendurch auch mal ein
bisschen bier trinken egal haben wir das
geklärt mit cristiano ronaldo es gibt
eine sehr sehr sehenswerte dokumentation
über dein leben im speziellen aber auch
felix spielt darin eine große rolle der
eltern tauchen darin auf dass die türen
das sehr weit aufgemacht und für mich
als fußballfan toll dass zu sehen warum
macht ihr das in der art und weise warum
jetzt gut jetzt in erster linie weil
jetzt die anfrage kam
aber es hätte ja noch irgendwie sich
nach dem ende der karriere zum beispiel
seien möglicherweise ja aber ich finde
es erstmal eine riesen auszeichnung dass
sowas schon während der karriere kommt
das meist und hat bis jetzt schon
einiges richtig gemacht
ich glaube dass die anfrage auch genau
deswegen kam weil man von mir außerdem
fußball datum den großen noch nicht so
viel wusste spricht vielleicht auch
spannend ist dass das herauszufinden und
natürlich habe ich ein paar stunden tage
auch überlegt ob ich das machen soll
weil das eigentlich nicht zu meinem
naturell passt der kamera oft dabei zu
haben genau fand aber einfach diese
wurden in dem film das wird man auch
sehen auch nicht gewisse grenzen
überschritten ich habe mehr gezeigt als
es bis dahin je gemacht habe aber das
war mir auch klar wenn ich diese anfrage
zu sagen weil ich weiß auch dass wenn
die leute ins kino gehen wollen die
nicht ausschließlich fußball sehen von
mir sehen weil die kennt jeder
sondern dann interessiert die leute
natürlich auch was ist ein bisschen
dahinter und ich hab's einfach gemacht
weil kinofilm ist für mich wie eben
schon gesagt die anfrage kinofilme ist
ja in vielen anderes brett als irgendwie
eine kleine weiß nicht oder was auch
immer und es ist ein bisschen eigentlich
wiener biografie
zu schreiben und ich finde immer wenn
man die biografie schreibt schreibt man
sie entweder wirklich komplett ehrlich
oder gar nicht alles andere ist fake
news hast du ihm dazu geraten felix das
zu machen erstmal noch mal zu der frage
wann also ich war mit meiner dann nach
meiner karriere
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ich habe ihm dazu geraten noch abgeraten
also im endeffekt weiß ich dass er seine
entscheidung selber klar und noch gerne
und ich glaube es auch das ist wenn man
so eine anfrage bekommen die man nicht
wirklich jeden tag bekommt dann sollte
man die chance auch nutzen das wird
immer leute geben die das gut finden das
nicht so gut finden aber ich glaube wenn
man den film ansieht ich habe das noch
nicht gesehen das habe ich schon mal
kurz rein kleiner trailer und der
erklärt sehr sehr viel bringt seine
besondere fähigkeit besteht darin das
spiel anders zu sehen als die anderen
[Musik]
bin ich runter schaut wo sich die weiße
schuhe und socken wir uns einfach zu
hause in der nähe von den kindern zu
sagen wir leben sondern als das eher
gelassen hat er von seiner großen wurde
von mir ganz wichtig europa sagt ein
erster hat da nicht so verlaufen haben
zwei neue kraft hast das haben wir ein
riesentalent ist dann hat man auch den
ehrgeiz kinder in den bezahlten fußball
zu bringen
ich habe hier gesessen
[Musik]
spieler der von bayern münchen kommt
gerade weltmeister geworden ist was
besseres kann nichts passieren
spaß gemacht herr sommer
[Musik]
große spieler sind technisch tag in
ihren wird vielmehr entschieden hat es
mit den füssen
[Musik]
groß ist die ideale verkörperung was das
ausland an deutschland erkennt deutsches
handwerk deutsche ernsthaftigkeit
deutscher sonnenbrand
der größten dirigenten der deutsche
fußball hat
[Applaus]
gratuliere
ich würde gerne felix zu beginn frage
ist wie schaust du auf seine karriere
der größtmöglichen stolz also ich werde
auch immer gerne gefragt ob ich neidisch
bin auf den erfolg den er hat und das
sag ich immer die gleiche antwort ich
bin derjenige sich am meisten freut über
über seinen erfolg und wenn man mich
beobachten würde wie ich bei seinem
spielen vor dem fernseher sitze da weiß
wie nervös und aufgeregt ich habe gerade
bei den finanz jetzt mittlerweile nicht
mehr genug gewonnen
[Gelächter]
einfach unfassbar stolz weil ich habe
seinen weg von anfang an mitverfolgt
wir haben jede minute zur kindheit
verbracht und das dann so was daraus
wird so eine karriere mit dem wir
zusammen begonnen haben auch auf dem
fußballplatz
das hatte man sich niemals erträumt und
das mit dem neid kann ich nur bestätigen
ich glaube tatsächlich dass du jemanden
bisher mit den worten halt nichts
anfangen kann der auch sehr
selbstbewusst durch sein leben geht und
der sehr genau weiß wie gut er auch
selber ist wann war dir klar dass dein
bruder möglicherweise über ein talent
verfügt das vielleicht nur eine handvoll
fußballer überhaupt auf der welt hat ja
natürlich sieht man sowas wenn man ein
bisschen was von fußball versteht dass
da schon etwas besonderes da gehört am
ende auch immer dann glück dazu dass man
den erfolg hat damit dass auch dann
wahrgenommen wird ja aber es war schon
von frühester kindheit irgendwo zu sehen
dass er immer besser war als alle
anderen und ich konnte noch ganz gut
mithalten ist in gewissen zeitpunkt aber
was was in der sache ist wann bis wann
bist du dann von zu hause weg soll dann
konnte nicht mal eins gegen eins im
garten spielt
aber das war schon schon relativ früh zu
sehen und wie gesagt man brauche noch
ein bisschen glück verletzungs freiheit
aber das war ein großer erfolg haben
würde die wahrscheinlichkeit war relativ
hoch
ich habe ein interview altes interview
von dir gefunden indem du sagst es war
merkwürdig weil ich habe immer
wahnsinnig gekämpften und der toni hat
das immer so lässt sich leicht gemacht
das kann man sich vorstellen wie ich das
immer aufgeregt hat
[Musik]
ist ja auch mal sachen gespielt haben
roman tennis gespielt sonst was wenn du
auf anderen seite schauen sich immer
kaputt gelacht hat und ich da vor wut
geschwitzt aber auf anderen seite das
war
da waren wir schon verschieden aber
schönes bild übrigens nun ja sehr schön
ist das ist das eure badminton phase
eigentlich brauche eure mutter nun mal
eine große badmintonspielerin erst
richtig im kopf der betten na ja die war
ddr meister sogar haben
unser früheste kindheit in der batman
alle verbraucher sind der erste wird man
ein bisschen mit aufgewachsen aber es
ging relativ schnell zum fußball und
badminton wir dann noch ein bisschen
kokolores nebenbei kokolores badminton
war kokolores nebenbei ja das ist ein
satz den lassen wir jetzt mal so stehen
es wird die badminton clubs in
deutschland sehr freuen wenn du das ja
so sagt ist ja klar ist wie es gemeint
ist offensichtlich habe dir dabei denn
herausragendes talent weil euer vater
hat sich dann sehr intensiv um euch dann
gekümmert toni war dir klar dass du da
vielleicht eine gabel vom lieben gott
geschenkt bekommen hast und diese
leichtigkeit von der den bruder gerade
so doch ein bisschen neidisch spricht
wenn er zu sagen hat
die andere nicht haben natürlich merkt
man das sage ich mal wenn man die übung
mit den anderen zusammen macht und in
der mannschaft mit dem zusammenspiel
dass man irgendwie vielleicht die übung
oder die neue übung vielleicht beim
ersten oder zweiten mal schon relativ
einfach hin bekommen die anderen kämpfen
beim 56 mal noch da merkt man schon dass
man vielleicht irgendwas mit bekommen
hat weil das hat ja in dem wir noch
nichts mit arbeit zu tun einfach
vielleicht irgend ein bewegungstalent
irgendein gefühl im fuß was was einfach
ein bisschen besser ist aber ich werde
mich immer sehr dagegen zu sagen dass
das eben das talent mich da hingebracht
hat weil das verstehe ich aus diesem
talent dann das zu machen
das ist dann mittelfristig genauso viel
arbeit noch mal und von daher das ist da
das ist der mix also mit nur mit talent
würde es keiner dahin schaffen du
könntest du vielleicht auch irgendwie in
den bezahlten fußball kommen wenn ein
außergewöhnliches talent hast ja aber
nur mit arbeit
kannst du das schaffen ja das würde ich
jetzt zum beispiel in meinem fall so
nicht sagen
also was soll das talent für
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig also ich
könnte mich anstrengen wie viel ich
wollte
das liebeslied aber was ich mir in der
vorbereitung gefragt habe es gibt leute
im fernsehen zum beispiel von kollegen
weiß ich dass wir jetzt keine namen
nennen aber von frank plasberg war sich
das zum beispiel der sagt lassen nach
dem urlaub hat er manchmal das gefühl
oder die angst ich kann das jetzt nicht
mehr
kennst du dieses gefühl und ihr beide
also das gefühl dort irgendwann verliere
ich vielleicht diese sicherheit diese
diese selbstsicherheit und er kann ich
diesen tödlichen pass nicht mehr spielen
eigentlich nein es ist schon so wenn man
lange urlaub hatte dass man manchmal so
ein zwei tage so ein bisschen braucht
was dann wieder heißt man braucht ein
bisschen arbeit aber dieses
grundsätzliche gefühl für den ball was
du jahrelang gemacht hast und da kam ich
eben wieder zurück zu dem talent was dir
auch trotz langer pause einfach keiner
nimmt das hast du das hast du nicht und
und wie gesagt ich kann ganz viele
andere sachen nicht also du zu hause
beim radfahren oder so da kann ich
nichts anfangen aber im fußball eben
schon der der vater hat euch beide
trainiert dieser hatte dieser verdacht
war das gut oder schlecht findet noch
mal wenn der vater der trainer ist ist
das gut oder schlecht die hat das beides
also endeffekt auch sportliche bezogen
ja ist ja was draus geworden also von
daher war das schon sehr gut hat uns
extrem gefördert haben sehr viel zu
verdanken
in der hinsicht natürlich hast du dann
auch 24 stunden am tag das thema fußball
wird dann jeder trainingseinheit
irgendwo ausgewertet oder vielleicht mal
als 15 60 nicht mehr so bock drauf hast
und ob irgendwo andere sachen kommen was
aber irgendwann ist das ja jetzt auch da
hingebracht und geprägt ja immer wenn
ich diesen gesichtsausdruck sich sagen
katholik als auch kalt sagen ja extrem
gut gelaunter mensch
das ergebnis schöne szene aus dem film
ist toll wie er darüber reflektieren auf
dem foto auf dem foto sieht man es jetzt
nicht so aber habt ihr schon mal darüber
nachgedacht ob möglicherweise euer vater
und jupp heynckes ein und dieselbe
person sind die sehen sie ja also wir
müssen jetzt noch vielleicht noch so 15
jahre von mein papa war der gerne auch
mal eine serie schwerer richtung geplant
ist habt ihr das was er gerade
besprochen hat habt ihr das zu hause
dann auch mal besprochen habt ihr euch
darüber ausgetauscht auch was felix
gerade sagte es war nicht immer einfach
nicht wirklich und was ich auch gerade
dann in dem film gesagt habe dass bei
uns nicht so an der tagesordnung war
auch gefühle zu reden oder über das was
in einem vorgeht
ja das ist auch heutzutage noch schwer
ehrlich gesagt
deswegen haben wir ja auch noch ziemlich
groß groß ausgewertet aber der zeitpunkt
wird sicher kommen und es ist ja auch
nicht so dass irgendwas schlimmes
passiert das ist ja nicht nichts was man
nicht irgendwo dann noch aus der welt
schaffen kann oder was schlimmer ist
deswegen wird bestimmter zeitpunkt
kommen wo man dann auch mal wieder
zusammen am tisch und darüber reden kann
und das wird dann auch schön aber heißt
das noch mal ganz kurz nachzufragen dass
ihr unter diesem den ehrgeizigen papa
dann auch gelitten hat manchmal nein das
ist ein zu großes wort aber gelitten
habe ich nie und wie gesagt im großen
und ganzen finde ich auch einfach nur
dankbarkeit dafür für diese
unterstützung die wir hatten und wir
hatten eine wohl behütete kindheit also
wir haben uns dann an nichts gefehlt und
das ist dass das muss man auch ganz klar
sagen aber es hat trotzdem preis toni
wie oft hatte man das gefühl sie
wenn ihr jetzt vom training nach hause
komme dann wäre es schön wenn da am
abendbrottisch man nicht der trainer
sitzen würde sondern einfach der papa im
nachhinein wäre das sicher wertvoll
gewesen sind es für das heutige
verhältnisse will ich es richtig gesagt
wir haben ein wirklich gutes verhältnis
mit mit unseren papa was hat sich ebenso
entwickelt dadurch dass er sonst in dem
moment damals ja gar nicht so
aufgefallen ist man uns hat er selbst
gemacht über fußball zu reden
in dem moment hat man es aber glaube ich
so ein bisschen verpasst und ich glaube
das ist auch schwer als 14 15 60 jährige
als irgendwie das zu sagen lasst uns mal
was anderes sprechen oder über was uns
sonst beschäftigt wir haben vater ein
thema aber ich glaube dass man das im
nachhinein sagen kann dass das halt in
der phase so viel bisschen verpasst
wurde
und das ist auch nicht mehr wenn man
erwachsen ist mit einem fingerschnippen
dann wiederholen weil wir sind an
unseren eigenen weg gegangen ich habe
eine familie ich habe eine frau ich habe
meine drei kinder ich habe freunde
kennengelernt auf dem weg seitdem ich
mit 16 weg gegangen bin und mit dem man
das eben jetzt teilt und das hat sich
ebenso entwickelt deswegen ist für mich
ganz wichtig zu sagen ich habe ein gutes
verhältnis zu meinem papa und das hat
sich einfach nicht so entwickelt dass
man über die innigsten gefühle täglich
spricht mit eben was natürlich rückblick
ein bisschen schade ist dafür hat er uns
in anderen sachen halt extrem geholfen
hat dir geholfen dass du mit 16 dann die
entscheidung getroffen hast zu bayern zu
gehen
ja also ich hab halt wirklich bis dahin
und dann natürlich auch weiter aber vor
allem bis dahin natürlich dem fußball so
viel untergeordnet weil wir auch als
familie dass wir eben den den weg jetzt
weiter gehen wollten ja profi zu werden
erfolgreich zu sein und so musste man so
schwer es mir natürlich damals privat
gefallen dass weg zu gehen gerade von
meinem bruder mit dem ich kann jede wir
uns gesagt hat alles geteilt haben ja
sogar ein zimmer bisher glaube ich 14
war und dann hatten wir dann glaube ich
jeder ein eigenes so schwer mir das
gefallen ist konnte ich dann nicht mit
16 sagen so jetzt schauen wir dass der
fußball die die die zweite geige spielt
dann musste ich auch durchziehen und der
beste schritt war eben damals bayer
mensch finde ich wie ging es dir damals
ich meine da verliert man ja nicht nur
den bruder
sondern den besten freund mit 14 hat
dann vielleicht auch so eine art
leidensgefährten ist jetzt auch ein
großes wort aber du weißt was ich meine
dieser diese hat da dieses selbe thema
du bist allein zu hause aber dadurch
halt auch die ungeteilte aufmerksamkeit
eltern ja aber mit 14
[Applaus]
nein es war sehr schwer wir haben alles
zusammen gemacht werden die gleichen
interessen
es war richtig schwer ist es auch
weiterhin ehrlich gesagt weil seit dem
zeitpunkt auch wir uns wirklich auch
sehr selten sehen wir haben wunderbar
arglos danke dass wir uns zusammen
[Applaus]
weshalb man heute hier fast fast auf rtl
bringen können wie so ein
zusammentreffen wieder ist und da
wirklich
vielleicht kommt noch wäre entweder
umher
ja ja ja aber das ist sowieso das ist ja
auch immer halt noch der fall ist dass
wir uns da so selten sehen oder sogar
noch schwer ist und muss unser termin
kann da sind ähnlich wir haben haben
wenig zeit ist auch bei felix die
champions league einmal das ist auch
einfach wie gesagt es ist weiterhin
schwer und das ist das was ist das
größte opfer ist von der ganzen fußball
geschichte das ist man wirklich die
leute die haben am wichtigsten sind es
natürlich toni aber auch zum beispiel
geburtstage von den großeltern runde
geburtstage von den eltern
du kannst einfach nicht du hast ein
spiel und training bis zum
trainingslager oder sonstwo und dass das
große größter warst du als fußballer
bringst und genau das sehen viele leute
nicht glaube ich die immer nur davon
sehen fussball alles schön und gut und
die sehen die badelatschen von gucci
oder so dass keiner das heißt jetzt
nicht dass das ist weiterhin auch sehr
schwierig nicht nur seit dem zeitpunkt
sondern auch die letzten zwölf jahre um
das wird wohl noch ein paar jahre so
gehen also das ist so hätten bis heute
ist das eine nicht fertige geschichte
für dich die trennung von seinem bruder
absolut ich habe das gefühl dass wir
noch so viel zusammen zu machen haben
und zu erleben haben und zeit
miteinander zu haben dass das ist
einfach zu wenig gewesen den letzten
zwölf jahren und das schwer geht es auch
so ja klar
also natürlich ist es sage ich mal mein
tag ist sage ich mal trotzdem extrem
voll da weil sowie von gesagt hat man
man ist ja seinen weg gegangen
man man ist trotzdem extrem beschäftigt
aber natürlich dass es das ist eine
geschichte die es nicht beendet ist wir
reden seit jahren davon dass wir uns
sehr darauf freuen dass wir irgendwie
nach unseren karrieren
selbst entscheiden können wann und wie
lange wir uns dann mal sehen und das ist
eine geschichte die ist dieses für felix
schwer das weiß ich dass dies für mich
extrem schwer und wir sehen uns
ungelogen zwei dreimal im jahr nicht
nicht öfter und dann auch meist nur für
zwei drei tage weil ja viel länger ist
geben die terminkalender nicht
man sieht in dieser dokumentation eure
mutter hat sehr gelitten
für die war das glaube ich ganz ganz
schwer sagt ihr habt viel geweint als
als toni dann plötzlich weg war wie war
es für dich mit 16 alleine plötzlich im
ausland ist hätte ich fast gesagt in
bayern münchen ist münchen ist ja ein
schönes umfeld und das hat eine schöne
stadt und die macht seinem eher leichter
anzukommen aber aber du bist 16 du bist
ganz alleine ich habe das selber so
erlebt mit elf internat und so das wirst
du so schnell ich wieder los nein klar
also die stadt ersetzt ja nicht die
leute die dich bis dahin gebracht haben
so sehr das ist ja klar von daher war es
natürlich auch für mich schwierig die
erste zeit ich bin oder ich bin da was
das wird manchmal kleinen tick
emotionslose als vierter das der familie
vielleicht oder wie es auch meine mama
ich hab es auch dann irgendwie erst im
film auch gesehen
denn der hat also ich wusste natürlich
dass es ihr schwerfällt aber da darf da
brauche ich nicht die aussage dazu das
weiß ich so und das wird ist natürlich
selbstverständlich aber sie sagt sie
sagt im film einsatz wo sie sagt sie hat
nach wie vor also nachdem ich gegangen
bin
für vier leute gedeckt jeden abend zu
hause und das war wirklich ein satz der
mich emotional so ein bisschen getappt
stattet das nicht einfach